muy buenas tardes para todos ustedes
pues de dominica team quien hacía su
regreso a este gran slam después de
muchos meses de estar por fuera de las
canchas y ese regreso que finalmente
pues no tuvo un final feliz aquí en
parís y fue el boliviano hugo dellien
quien se quedó con ese partido en tres
sets 6-3 6-2 6-4 ya viene lesionado de
un su muñeca derecha y bueno por lo
visto pues por ahora el austriaco
necesita continuará trabajando en eso
porque por ahora pues no tiene no
consigue ese nivel que ya tuvo acá
cuando él de hecho fue dos años
consecutivos finalista de este torneo y
la otra buena noticia eso sí para
latinoamérica viene en el cuadro
femenino gracias a maría camila osorio
la colombiana quien venció a la francesa
armó ni tan en dos sets 6-4 6-3 sin
mayor problema y una mejor presentación
para usuario que el año pasado que había
sido eliminada en la primera ronda
y que otros partidos hay destacados para
esta jornada
bueno entre ahora que usted hablaba de
sorpresas la primera sorpresa gran
sorpresa de este torneo es la
eliminación de la tunecina ons jabeur
laviana perdió ante la polaca magdalena
de a pesar de que había ganado el primer
el primer set lo cierto es que la
tunecina fue perdiendo pues fue
perdiendo la confianza que había logrado
tras conseguir ese primer set y
finalmente línea después subo supo
aprovechar las oportunidades y quedarse
finalmente con este partido no sabemos
quién es la número 6 del mundo y que se
esperaba pues tuviera una gran
participación en este torneo en el día
de hoy esperábamos también el partido de
alexander zverev el alemán jens va a
jugar ante el austríaco sebastian
haffner y por supuesto pues que este día
va a terminar por un partido que muchos
estarán esperando un duelo
iberoamericano que será entre el
argentino juan ignacio lóndero y el
español carlos alcaraz alcaraz
recordemos que fue pues el vencedor en
el torneo de miami en barcelona y
también en madrid y se espera pues que
él sea una de las grandes sensaciones de
este roland garros